so yeah I'll talk about home Orphic
encryption in this hour and the next
this hour would be mostly about somewhat
homomorphic encryption many of the
slides both this hour and the next are
taking from Craig there so let's get
started
for morphic encryption essentially is
just a way to delegate processing of
data without giving away straight access
to that data so here is probably the the
best type of application of this
technology there's Alice there she wants
the cloud to store her storage for her
and do the processing on that data for
her but she doesn't want the cloud to
see what's in there so she's going to
encrypt the data to the cloud she has
her X that she cares about later on
she's gonna send the function that she
wants the cloud to compute on X on her
behalf the function can be encrypted as
well or maybe in the clear the main
thing is the cloud should be able to run
some evaluation procedure on the
encrypted data and the description of
the function and this is really the
special sauce this is the similar thing
that's special about homomorphic
encryption it allows the cloud to do
this kind of processing and the time
that it takes to do this processing is
essentially the same as the time that it
would have taken to do the same
processing on the data in the clear up
to some polynomial factors in the
security parameter the cloud will return
the encryption of the result to Alice
and then Alice can use her secret key to
decrypt so that's the sort of the
typical or at least the most
straightforward application of computing
on encrypted data and one important
feature of this scenario is the fact
that Alice wants the cloud to do that is
because she wants to save work she
doesn't want to do all of her work so in
particular the work that Alice does
encrypting X and decrypting f of X
should be
smaller than the cost of computing f of
X from scratch ideally we would like
this cost to be completely independent
of the complexity of F so the amount of
work that the server is doing relates to
the complexity of f the amount of work
that the client is doing in this
application should not in terms of what
it is morphic encryption is first and
foremost it's an encryption scheme so
there is key generation there is an
encryption there isn't a crucian the
added source here is another procedure
this is a functionality requirement of
the encryption scheme an evaluation
procedure that you can apply to
encrypted data in terms of security
we're not talking about anything special
this is just the standard notion of
semantic security or passive security or
chosen plaintext security whatever you
want to call it but this is the basic
security requirement the thing that
makes it special is the correctness
requirement from the evaluation so what
we want is if you have a bunch of
messages and you're encrypting these
messages then you apply the evaluation
procedure on the resulting ciphertext
with some particular description of a
function f and decrypt the result what
you get is the thing that you expect to
get the application of F to the
underlying messages and the small amount
of work requirement for Alice comes into
play in the compactness requirement we
want the complexity of decrypting the
result sister to be independent of the
complexity of computing F so these are
the these are the procedures and what we
want from them
and before we start talking about this
thing let's just go through the analogy
here I'm sure many of you probably all
of you have seen that so here's Alice
she wants she has her raw material this
is her actual data she wants to assemble
it to this very valuable piece of
furniture furniture well maybe that too
Jewellery but she doesn't trust the
walker she doesn't want the walker to
have access to hook there were material
so what she would do is she would
encrypt this she would put it in a
locked box but it would be a special
lock box that allows somebody to process
things even while they're in that
lockbox and it's a glove box there so
the worker can come and with the gloves
assemble this piece of jewelry and then
Alice can use her key to get the result
out and at least for the purpose of this
presentation and actually in general
it's useful to think of her morphic
encryption as coming in two flavors
there's the somewhat homomorphic
encryption it lets you compute
unencrypted data but maybe not
everything you can compute some function
there is a class of functions that you
can compute on encrypted data and all
the things that we had before
Craig's 2009 work was of this variety so
you can compute additives func you can
compete linear functions or you can
compute branching programs or things
like that both 2009 the thing that we
also have is a fully owned morphic
encryption which means I have one system
one encryption scheme and I can compute
any function on the encrypted data that
I want one thing that's probably not
really needed in this audience but first
because it's recorded and second
actually whenever you describe a morphic
encryption to people who are not
cryptographers by training it's very
useful to go through this paradox and
explain why it's not really a paradox so
here is a particular application the
cloud has my encrypted files and my
public key so there is an encryption of
f1 f2 and later I want to do a private
information retrieval I want to fetch
one of these files without the cloud
knowing which of them I fetched so I'm
going to encrypt the index of the father
I'm interested in and send it to the
cloud and the cloud would evaluate the
lookup function the function that takes
as input all the files and
the index and return the correct one
okay so when it's said like this it
seems a little paradoxical because well
the server eventually is going to send
me an encryption of my third file and it
has an encryption of my third file can't
it just see that it sends me the third
one and of course the reason it's not a
paradox is because we're talking about
semantic secure encryption so it's
randomized and there are many encryption
of the same thing and identifying the
two things encrypt the same thing this
is the thing that security says that you
cannot do so with that let me before
starting talking about how to do home
morphic encryption let me talk a little
bit about properties of form of
encryption some limitations of it so let
me start from some properties properties
that anamorphic encryption may or may
not have one property that it definitely
does not have is chosen ciphertext
security this is malleable by design you
cannot possibly get the standard notion
of home of chosen ciphertext security if
your underlying encryption scheme is
homomorphic you can get weaker notions
so for example CCA e1 or the lunchtime
attack type maybe you can get that there
are other meaningful notions of non
malleability that apply to a morphic
encryption in particular or morphix
signatures is probably the most
interesting of them and maybe Daniel
will talk about it later on multi-hop
that's another from everything that I
said before I said that once you encrypt
your data you can compute on it using
the eval procedure there's a question of
whether once you computed it and you get
this C star can you keep computing on it
after the fact most schemes that we have
yes the answer is yes you can not always
and there are some things that you can
do if your criticism doesn't support it
you can fix it so it does support it at
least to some extent functional privacy
whether or now let's say that it's not
Alice who chooses the function to
compute it's the server that decides
what is it that it wants to compute
it just gets the result can Alice tell
what the function was well on some sense
because the size of the ciphertext
doesn't grow if the complexity of f it
clear that it clear that there is some
loss of information there but maybe
Alice can still did decide whether it
was f1 or f2 that was computed the
constructions that we have don't
necessarily come with function privacy
especially not in the case where you
care about malicious security were
Alice's public key was malformed or
maybe the ciphertext was malformed so
sometimes you need to pay attention to
that in the honest but curious where
everything was generated according to
the prescribed algorithms usually it's
easy to get function privacy out of the
constructions that we have in also in
general actually something that we not
mentioned before I'm going to mention it
in just a few more details for
homomorphic encryption the distinction
between secret key encryption and public
key encryption is not important there is
an easy generic black box transformation
are constructing one from the other this
is the theorem by one what bloom from
four years ago and it goes like this the
construction and n it's proof of are
fairly simple so I'm just going to do
them on the slides well you have a
secret key encryption scheme and you
want to make a public encryption scheme
out of it so you need to publish
something as your public key what would
it be what it would be is just a
collection of many random bits and the
encryption of those bits so many pairs
bi CI well CI is an encryption of BI and
how many of them well that depends on
how large your ciphertext gets if the
ciphertext is of some length you need to
choose more bit than it takes to
represent a single ciphertext now that
you have that if you want to encrypt a
bit Sigma what you do is you choose
another random bit string R such that
the inner product between your bit
string and the bit string in the public
key gives you the bit that you want to
encrypt and then you just come
to morphic inner product you just take
the summation of all the CIS
corresponding to our I equals one this
is just the mod to inner product of R&B
and because this is additive
neuromorphic then the result is a
ciphertext that actually encrypts the
beat that you wanted so here it is again
the public here is this set of is the
set of tears B and C to encrypt you
choose a random R and you compute
homomorphic in a product correctness is
immediate from the fact that this is a
morphic encryption and security is
actually fairly easy to see the only
observation you need really is that the
transformation from the bit string R to
the end result ciphertext C loses
information where you started from L
beats you ended up with a ciphertext at
X less than L bits to represent you lost
some information there and now you can
think of this C as some leakage that
tells you something about your about
your original R and if you for a second
imagine that all the encryptions are
encryptions of 0 as opposed to
encryptions of B then this is
essentially the only thing that's the
only piece of information that you get
about your random randomness and since
the inner product is very good in
leakage resilient then it means that you
cannot predict just seeing C you cannot
predict the inner product between B and
R and since this is an secure encryption
scheme then you cannot tell the
difference between having their
encryptions of bits and having
encryptions of videos so that's pretty
much the entire transformation and it's
proof and it's very convenient when
right so you write but once you switch
to this all 0 then there's nothing
nothing related to be there so and it's
really convenient when working for
morphic encryption scheme because as we
know did you can always describe your
crypto system in terms of a secret key
encryption scheme and then just wave
your hands and say
there is a public healer some things
that morphic encryption doesn't do so it
doesn't do application what office
question is we'll hear about it later in
this bootcamp but essentially I can give
the cloud an encryption encrypted
program and then the cloud can evaluate
that encrypted program on inputs of its
choice and get the answer and it learns
nothing about my program in some sense
other than the output
the main difference well you can encrypt
your program and have the the cloud run
it on instances of its choice also when
you use a morphic encryption but in the
case of a morphic encryption once you've
done computing the thing that you have
in your hand is a ciphertext and you
don't know what it is unless you have
the secret key question you actually get
the result in the clear and that's a
very big difference indeed we know that
obfuscation you cannot do a full scan if
it's strong enough for certain type of
obfuscation are impossible in general
other types of application are possible
under some assumptions and again we will
see more of that later in this workshop
another thing that to morphic encryption
doesn't do is random access so yeah in
terms of being able to compute something
circuits can compute anything that any
other normal reasonable model for
computation does but the complexity is
not always the same it's more or less
the same as the computer capacity of
Turing machines it's not always the same
as the complexity of random access
machines first of all there is a
quadratic or cubic blow-up in every
computation but in some settings where
those pre encrypted data ahead of time
like a sorted array for example with
random access you can access something
in logarithmic many years steps whereas
with circuits it has it has to be linear
and home Orphic encryption doesn't do
that can't do random access and in
general you can't do random access
unencrypted data because it's encrypted
and you don't know water well what's
what's in it what we can do there is an
oblivious Ram there
solutions that do work in run complexity
or close to that but they're very
interactive typically you can use the
patient to do oblivious Raman that get
get rid of some of the interaction for
you and I don't think we will hear about
it in this workshop but I'm not sure
maybe how morphic encryption doesn't do
multi key so so far I was talking about
Alice as the one doing the encryption
and everything done under Alice's key
but there are multiple people in the
world and all of them have the wrong
keys and maybe you want to compute on
data that came from different people and
is encrypted under different keys or
morphic encryption out-of-the-box
doesn't necessarily do that for you
there are constructions there that can
do this and hopefully I will have time
to talk about one of them so with that
I'm sort of done talking about what home
morphic encryption is and what the
properties it does or doesn't have so
let's talk a little bit about how to
construct them and essentially those you
know two easy steps the first expressive
function as a circuit with addition and
multiplication gate and then design a
crypto system that encrypts beaten and
can support additional multiplication
that's easy enough the second thing is
of course well the hard part is the
first one is generic so let's start from
a toy example this is from the American
scientist magazine so imagine for a
second that multiplication by two was a
secure encryption scheme for some reason
well then you have a morphic encryption
just multiply everything by two do you
want to add them we'll add the
ciphertext that would give you write
three and five was is your data six and
ten is the encryption 16 is indeed an
encryption of eight that works nicely if
you want to multiply well it almost
works right I mean six and ten when you
multiply them you don't really get the
30 that you expect which is encryption
you have to divide by two so your multi
why each other 1/2 and that gives you an
encryption of you so yeah that's a sort
of maybe a silly example but the thing
that it does actually bring across is
this notion of homomorphism and I want
to spend two slides talking about it at
least in our head when we think about
more encryption schemes that supports
additional implication most of us have
this notion of home morphism this is why
it was called by reverse admin and the
toussis homomorphic privacy morphism
there is the space of plaintext which is
a ring in this case ring of integers mod
2 and then there's the space of
ciphertext which would think of us also
ring and we would like to have this
commutative diagram that mathematicians
have when they're talking about
homomorphism there is this encryption
that relates the two rings and then
there is the addition and multiplication
operations within the ring and you can
apply the operation in the ring of
plaintext and then encrypt or you can
apply the operator or you first encrypt
and then apply the oppression and you
want to get the same thing this is the
thing that we have in mind when we think
of homomorphic encryption and it comes
with four warning the warning is that
yeah it's a nice intuition you shouldn't
take it too literally because if it was
really homomorphism in this form then
encryption of zero would have been a
subspace a linear subspace or an ideal
more generally and then you know whether
you can identify encryption of a zero is
a question of whether you can have an
algebraic structure and an ideal inside
of that algebraic structure where you
can actually hide the ideal and there
were attempts going that way poly cocker
is probably the most noticeable of them
but they were all eventually broken we
don't know how to hide an ideal in in a
in a ring that actually supports all
these operations what we want to do so
what do we do instead
you can write if you think of gold Asami
Carly encryption that's exactly what
happens there well it's only additives
but you do have a linear subspace
adjustment you cannot do Gaussian
elimination in this representation yep
so what we can do is to the side that we
like linear algebra and we're gonna
build our thing on linear algebra but
we're gonna add a little bit of noise
into it so that you cannot solve it
that's essentially what's going on in
all of these constructions each stifle
text has some noise in it that hides the
message message and you can think about
it in in the terms of error correcting
code it's the thing that you really mean
is the code world the thing that you
show me is the code word if L well Alice
knows the some good representation of
the error correcting code and with that
representation she can correct but that
only holds if the error is small enough
because if the error is too large then
no matter in what you know the code if
you have a points here in the in the
purple area you don't know which point
it came from so with that let me
describe perhaps the easiest crypto
system to describe in one or two slides
home Orphic encryption over the integers
the main idea encryptions of zero are
something small and even more secret
integers so you have a secret key which
is a secret odd integer the public key
would be integers there are multiple of
the secret key up to an small additive
error these are actually encryptions of
zero so it fits essentially the same
format of transforming secret key to
public key encryption by publishing
encryptions of zero to encrypt you take
a subset sum and you add your message to
the crypt you compute you take your
cipher text mode and and that leaves you
with only the error which is either
either even or odd depending on what the
BQ encrypted and if you want to add and
multiply will just add and melted
over the integers if you make the right
hardness assumption it's even secure say
anything more about that well you know
since the thing that happens you have
the multiple of the secret key and then
the distance to the multiple of the
secret key the multiples just get adds
and multiplied and then fall off once
you do decryption the error is worried
you're actually doing the work and when
you give up as long as you don't wrap
around this secret key of yours then the
arrow the multiplication and addition is
also happening over the integers so in
particular the mod 2 version of it
happens mode 2 it's not so again since
it's a morphic encryption how do you do
the encryption is not very important the
point is encryption of 0 is something
whose that were the distance to the
nearest multiple of n is even encryption
of 1 is what the distance to the
multiplet is odd and as long as you
don't wrap around its tail this way so
when you add things you get the sum of
the errors when you multiply things you
get the product of the URLs and in
general when you apply any arbitrary
polynomial you get that polynomial
applied to the error as long as there's
no wraparound noise grows right you
apply some polynomial to integers these
integers grow and as soon as they hit n
over 2
well now you know is is too large and
you lost your in your data and that's a
problem so yeah you can if you know that
you want to do a computation of certain
complexity maybe you can make your
secret key large enough but that's a
problem because you know it has to have
enough room to grow
it goes exponentially with the degree so
the number of bits in you know is
grossly linearly with the degree if you
are something that you can express in
polynomial size you can only support
things of polynomial degree and
that's so from now on until I'm a close
to the probably in the middle of the
second hour I'm going to talk about
things that you can do to better control
the noise or get better assumptions and
things like that and since everything we
do in lattice based crypto we sort of
like it when it's based on lwe then this
is what I'm going to talk about I'm
going to talk about a morphic encryption
based on lwe the focus is gonna be on
the GSW scheme even though the first
schemes to do home Orphic encryption
bases lwe was Bukowski and I could to
Latin but this scheme is a little
simpler to describe so this is what I'm
going to describe the thing was just to
show the notion of noise and and the
noisy ciphertext and things I'm not
going to talk about it anymore because
it's the technical details they were
actually harder and less actually you
can connect it back to lwe this is the
recent work in your clip that show that
but it's a lot more complex and the road
is a lot more a lot longer this one is a
little less straightforward so let me go
back to something that we know described
in the previous hour and talk about
regular scripted system and just let me
warn you that my matrices of the
transpose of Vinod's matrices so vinod
matrices were short and fat mine would
be tall and skinny and you multiply on
the other side that's I mean the fact
that ten years after who dared think the
field hasn't converging one or the other
is just I guess were a testament to our
individualism I don't know right so the
secret key in the secret key in the
gives the encryption scheme was the
secret element yes and but if you want
to write it in a matrix form it's
easier to think about it as a vector
that has one in the first coordinate and
then the secret part of it later on and
the public key is a matrix which is
randoms except that if you multiply it
by the secret key you get something
small so in the notes description there
was a and then a vector B we package
these together in one matrix that we
call B and the property of that matrix
is when you multiply it by the secret
key you get something small to encrypt a
beat you choose a random 0 1 vector so
in particular vector with small
coordinates and you multiply it by the
secret key and then add Q over to time
your beat so in either ad cure to don't
up here the 2 to the first coordinate
when you decrypt you just take the inner
product between the secret key and the
ciphertext mod Q and then what you get
is well on one side you have R times B
times T B times T we already said is
small R is a small vector so the inner
product between R and B times T is also
small so all of this thing gives you
some small error vector and then you get
K over 2 times your bit so you recover
it as just the most significant bit of
the inner product so that's Regulus
encryption so some properties well one
property is that the ciphertext and
secret key of vectors are the first
enter in the secret key 'none it's
actually extremely useful for
manipulating things to have a secret key
where one part of it is not really
secret it lets you do all kind of things
later on small dot products if you have
an encryption of MU under T then the
inner product is nu times Q plus
something small and this is exactly how
he decrypted and in terms of security
it's actually a little goes a little
beyond semantic security so ciphertext
actually pseudo-random if decision LW is
hard then ciphertext are in
distinguished
go from uniform vectors to an attacker
that doesn't know the secret key and we
know do that we not actually proved that
use the use decision lwe to argue that
you cannot distinguish the public key
from a random matrix and then you use
the leftover hash limit to argue that if
the matrix was completely random then
ciphertext would have been uniform right
uniformly random and the leg of the
encryption scheme is actually relatively
common homomorphic as it is because well
because you use the inner product for
decryption and if you using a product
for decryption then when you talk take
the sum to ciphertext and you do in a
product with the secret key well what
you get is the sum of the two things and
again as long as nothing wraps around Q
R then it what you get is an encryption
of the sum of the two bits duplicative
how morphism is a little more
complicated because well our ciphertext
are vectors and how do you multiply
vectors so there is one way you can
multiply vectors you can take tensor
product of vectors tensor product of two
that of two vectors is just the
collection of all the pairwise products
of the entries and actually does have
some of the properties that you want
because there is the thing called the
mixed product theorem that says that if
you take the inner product between two
tensor products is the same as taking
the two inner products and multiplying
them so you can think of the tendus
tensor product as encrypting the product
of the two bits under another secret key
which happens to be the tensile of the
other secret keys there are issues here
for example the side the dimension gets
squared with every multiplication and in
fact these issues can be solved this is
a book a scheme that could not unsure
how to make this thing work
but in this talk I'm going to take a
different route and turn the ciphertext
in to make
and then well we know how to multiply
matrices so that would be easier so
let's try to make things into matrices
key generation is going to be just the
same as before we have a secret key
which is the same vector with one in the
first coordinate and the rest secret if
you want to encrypt well what you do now
is you take a matrix that corresponds of
that matrix all encryptions of zero so
in particular it means that c0 this is a
matrix encryption of zero when you
multiply it by the secret key you get
something small and then your ciphertext
is going to be this encryption of 0 plus
the bit that you want to encrypt times
the identity matrix so before well I'll
show why it works let's just take I mean
at the sec talk about security by the
security of regular encryptions we said
that cipher texts are pseudo-random so
in particularly c0 is pseudo-random for
attacker that doesn't know the secret
key and therefore also the ciphertext C
pseudo-random so security is covered to
decrypt well to decrypt what you do is
again you take a product between the
ciphertext and the secret key and what
you get is C 0 times T that gives you a
small error and nu times I times T that
gives you mu times T so the end result
is your beat times the secret key plus
something small and then you decrypt to
0 if this is closer to the 0 vector we
need to keep to 1 if this is closer to
your secret key so before that we sort
of had Q over 2 versus 0 now we have
your secret key versus 0 so yeah the
figure-eight key in this case would have
to be slightly big so that you can
actually make this determination this
distance between T and 0 should be
larger than here
guess but it's the first drive gonna
change it anyway but the nice thing
about it he'll the secret kick you can
think about it as an approximate
eigenvector of the ciphertext so when
you multiply the ciphertext by the
secret key what you get is roughly the
scalar mu times your secret key up to
some small error so let's talk a little
bit about how to do homomorphism but
let's start from an even simpler case
well there is no error let's let's
imagine for a second that the secret key
is an actual eigenvector of your
ciphertext so you have a ciphertext
matrix you have a message which is the
eigenvalue of a secret key which is the
eigenvector and in this case well CI
times T is mu I is time T this is this
means CI encrypts me I relative to the
secret key T well now you have two
matrices with the same eigenvectors so
you can add and multiply them and the
eigenvalues are and multiply that's easy
to see but we but yeah well that
wouldn't be secure without the air so
let's see what happens when you do have
it here so addition works addition
everything is linear and the arrow just
adds up and we're good
multiplication multiplication almost
works let's just open it and see what
happens right so you multiply your
matrices straight out and now we try to
decrypt the result then it will C 1
times C 2 times T C 2 times T is this
approximate eigenvector you have u 2
times T up to an error so the only added
term here that you got is this is what
we want and this is the additional term
that we have C 1 times e 2 and you keep
doing that and eventually what you get
is what you wanted this is the term mu 1
times mu 2 times T is what you get in
the error free case and then the error
the error
terms which is the second message time
the first arrow plus the second error
times the first ciphertext so it's
somewhat as symmetric in nature and
that's the nuno is and if we want to
have some amorphous I'm going we need to
control it we need to argue that this
news noise is small if the original
noises were so there are two parts of
the noise and we need to deal with each
one of them separately one part is
relatively easy mew 2 times e 1 well mu
is the plaintext how do you make sure
that the plaintext remains small well
we'll just say that it's always 0 1 and
we're going to work with NAND gates so
it would stay 0 1 and therefore this
thing is we shouldn't really worry about
it this one is a little harder this one
when c1 is a matrix and it's actually a
pseudo-random matrix it's not small so
this thing well that's not small so we
need to do something else and can we
flatten somehow the product can we make
an equivalent product that has the same
properties in terms of homomorphism but
will we sort of represent this matrix by
a matrix that does have a small
coordinate so that so that there is a a
rabbit out of the Hat and actually
walking in in lattice based crypto over
the years these rabbits tend to pop out
every time there is a problem and you
know usually when they do it's usually a
G or a P of V or some combination of
them that are very fun but by now we
have our herd of rabbits that we can use
for various thing and this is the first
one this is something that we know it
should have covered in his talk but it
wasn't given the time so I'm gonna do
I'm gonna talk not very long but I'm
gonna talk about this for a little bit
how do you represent it's a way of
representing matrix of low dimension
with big entries by a matrix of larger
dimension with small entries
essentially what it is this idea was
used in the lattice trapdoor
construction it was implicit already in
I times original one in 99 and it became
explicit eventually with me Chen Xuan
Picard what I want is a gadget matrix
and it's inverse transformation so I
have some matrix G and I have an inverse
transformation that's not linear this is
just a transformation that I can compute
and the properties that I need are the
following so it takes any matrix which
has small dimensions it has m rows and n
columns so it's long and skinny and it
makes it phat it makes it adds columns
to it so it takes a matrix e and
represented by another matrix that has
many more columns but all the entries
are small and it has the feature that
when you multiply it by G you get back
to your original C here's an example of
how to do that probably the simplest
example there is take all the entries in
your matrix and for each entry just
represented in binary
well you multiply the number of columns
by a log key
clearly this matrix has small entries
well as small as they can get they're
either 0 1 and what would G be G would
just be the way well how do you make an
integer out of bits you multiply them by
the powers of 2 so this is your G and
this is your G inverse transformation
one way to think about this G inverse G
& G inverse is that G is a special
matrix that makes it very easy to solve
sis and G inverse is just the
transformation that you apply when you
solve sis for that G it better present
that way of thinking about it is not
particularly important for our
application but it might be important
for other things so ok now we have our
gadget and now let's see how we make an
encryption scheme
out of it an encryption would now be a
matrix such that C times T is not new
times T plus error but new times T prime
plus L with T prime is G times T the
dimensions of things now changed before
that an encryption a ciphertext was a
square matrix now ciphertext is one of
these skinny thing and so this is M by M
this is M this is M so this is M this is
M and by M this is L and this is M and
it's easy to modify the encryption to
get this form one way to see that it's
easy is because well this is gonna be
homomorphic so we can always apply
Bloom's transformation but it's gonna be
useful maybe for us to see how to make
it instead of doing C's 0 plus mu times
the identity we do C 0 plus mu times
this gadget matrix G and that works
security follows from LW justice before
c0 was pseudo-random c0 still is
pseudo-random so when you add this thing
it remains the random additive a
morphism work just like it did before
because everything is additive and for
multiplication let's go for it
so now instead of multiplying the
matrices straight out we take the left
matrix and we apply this G inverse
transform to it so again dimensions M by
n m by n once you extend that M by M so
the matrices map the dimensions match
now when you multiply here you can open
the c2 times T now T prime is G times T
now we see that we have G inverse of
something times G so they cancel out you
get deals
see one back now you have c1 times T
okay now you can open this and
eventually you get something that looks
very similar to what we had before with
one crucial difference this is sort of
the error free term that we want this is
what we want and that's our error we
still have the same u2 times v1 but that
we don't care about we're gonna make
ensure that mu is always a bit zero one
but now instead of having the matrix e1
itself we have its expanded
representation and that's good because
that one had no matter what c1 was G
inverse of c1 has small entries so
that's how you know and and it is small
so let's summary let some of let's make
a summary of what we have so far we're
pretty much done with the encryption
scheme we have an encryption of a bit
new it's a matrix such that when you
multiply that matrix by by the secret
key what you get is mu times T prime
plus a little bit of error what T prime
is this G times T additive or more
morphism you just add the matrices and
the noise gets gets added which means
you know that's at most twice the
maximum between them multiplicative or
morphism well you multiply them except
you expand the one of the matrices
before doing that and the size of the L
grows a little bit more so a one just we
will get it or we don't eat too we
multiply it by a0 a1 matrix so the size
grows maybe by M where m is the
dimension and that's already somewhat
amorphic because the noise goes slowly
so how many times we can do that well we
need the arrow to be small smaller than
Q so that we don't get wraparound every
time we multiply it gets ma the L good
gets multiplied by at most M or M plus
one so oops
so well at the most log base M plus one
of Q levels we can we can process and I
think I have like 15 more minutes but I
pretty much done with left part right
I do have 15 more minutes so we can sing
along or something or maybe we can just
take the break earlier I'm not sure
let's take the break earlier because the
second part might be a little longer
than that so questions
the teeth 25 yes the second part might
be a little longer